[Music]
in the world of Hollywood action movies
you think that most people that you are
casting would have something later with
familiarity with action it turns out
that it's not the case a la people
actually need to be trained how to shoot
guns and how to how to look cool while
doing so I've mentioned there's dozens
of different styles of it I mean if you
look at you know Hollywood blockbusters
these days you have everything from Star
Wars such a sci-fi action to
transformers which is sci-fi action but
you also have other movies that are like
more military based ones like you know
I'm trying to think of them but I can't
but the point is is that there's lots of
different ways to approach this no are
you doing it like this you're doing that
like this are you doing it like this in
slow motion I mean there's a lot of ways
to do it
but we were doing something that it's
very military base so we needed our
actors to have that military kind of
style to the way they moved with weapons
and fought yeah now luckily Sam and I
have shot a lot of action stuff on our
core digital channel mm-hmm so we have a
little bit of a crash course that we've
run people through in the past and we
just gained this to all the actors so
each actor come into the studio
individually hmm we hand them an airsoft
gun we go over all the ways to hold the
gun the waist look cool while doing it
the ways to enter rooms how you need to
consider the space around you when
you're entering a gunfight and it kind
of work with them we do some little like
mini imaginary breaches and clearing and
fights and that kind of stuff and the
biggest most important thing here was
not necessarily exactly how they're
holding their gun but how they're
actually working with each other because
battlefield is all about squad based
combat and in the piece you know they're
operating these characters are operating
as squads so it's you know while it
might look cool if they're doing this or
doing that with a gun the main thing we
want them to focus on though was how
they are covering each other working
with each other and making sure that
they looked cool as a unit rather than
just cool by themselves they played
airsoft with them in Detroit we got we
had one day one of the first days when
the actors arrived I also haven't read
Lou Ferrigno's birthday um we have all
come together at the paintball place and
we played airsoft you know 3v3 2v2 is
pretty fun yeah just get them to the
idea of like you know here's
here's how you move here's how here's
how tired you get here's how you handle
corners here's how you have to
communicate with people because big
thing is volume you know if you're if
you're in a fight and yet to yell
somebody it's like until you're it even
just playing airsoft until you're at one
corner of a building need to yell
something another corner of a building
you don't quite know what volume you
need you know are you freaked out
yelling at the top of your lungs
you just talk can whisper what works
what doesn't how fast you have to talk
how you know you have to look at the
people behind you it's just all these
little things that you just do it a
couple times you want to do a ten day
boot camp thing just do these things a
couple times at least you have an
experience you can fall back on and
something you can think about at least
or some context and some grounding yeah
playing airsoft with everybody was very
crucial though because we got them to
actually kind of communicate and walk
and move together and kind of understand
you know how to move I mean it really
just comes back down to how to move as a
group without running into each other
yeah because that is like that the worst
thing to cease people like stacking up
and then like one person it's like
watching like a five car pileup on the
highway well you guys stops and
everyone's just blooming into any of
them so I've seen that happen
and we made sure that didn't happen
[Music]
okay so we lost freek large ego ran and
I got shot I fell over rude and
surrendered correct just just got
directed yeah we've been working on
YouTube videos over the last few years
and those have been consisting mostly
very short small pieces two minutes
crews have only anywhere between two to
ten people and everything is very very
small so we've kind of developed our own
style but working on this piece
obviously the crew size has exploded and
on set we've been working with 40 people
now this isn't just 40 people we found
you know randomly on Craigslist and just
you know we weren't asking people's you
know nephews and friends and friends to
help everyone on set for this piece was
a professional we were in Detroit
Michigan which has been home to the
number of humongous films over the last
few years one of the most recent ones
being Batman vs Superman so when we
hopped into town a lot of our crew had
just come off of that set in other large
movies so everyone was very experienced
everyone was very professional and so
for us to kind of come out to a set with
that type of crowd there's a very very
different experience than what we were
used to working with mostly because when
we're doing stuff by ourselves we're
doing everything so we're used to going
alright we're going to hold the camera
we're going to direct the actors we're
going to fix the costumes we're going to
drive the vehicle the set that we're
going to need to do heck we're going to
drive to the store and pick up some
snacks and Gatorade for everybody and
suddenly we're in this position where we
can focus completely on just our role in
the peace which is directing so it's
very nice it's great one of the biggest
lessons that I think we both learned
though from a piece like this is you
know understanding that kind of trust
and kind of going back to you know this
this squad working together and you know
moving as unit
and kind of stuff like that that was the
kind of training we had to go through
except with the whole crew now because
they're actually yeah because it's it's
a thing where you know we have a lot of
moving parts and a lot of things
happening every single day and
realistically you know we can't do all
that stuff so there's yeah very good
learning experience I'd say for us to
kind of you know delve into this and you
know really just let these professionals
you know do what they do so it took us a
little bit actually to get there and the
first few days we kind of were putting
our hands and everything a little bit
just because that's that's how we've
grown up learning how to make films and
so we had to kind of unlearn all these
things we've been doing over the last
few years to you know really you know
take advantage of what we had for us
[Music]
you